well hello there SCP fans let's get this
out of the way first you've seen the
title and thumbnail and you're probably
wondering wait is siren had an SCP and
the answer is no siren head is not an
SCP it's a freaky internet monster
created by renowned Canadian horror
artist Trevor Henderson your next
question is probably what's with this
crazy looking server Bank behind me
allow me to introduce you to the
anomatron 6000 the latest advancement of
supercomputing owned and operated
exclusively by the SCP Foundation it's
capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features calculating ideal containment
methods running state-of-the-art
Foundation web caller software making
and editing fun as CP YouTube videos but
the most interesting feature that the
animatron has to offer is running hyper
Advanced simulations regarding all
things anomalous with data fed into it
by thousands of real-life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation Nation
it's going to save countless dollars and
lives for foundation researchers but way
more importantly it's going to let us
explore all kinds of weird and wacky
what-if scenarios that would never
happen organically could scp-343 beat
Goku or Superman who's a deadly or
Supernatural killer
scp-106 or Freddy Krueger would the
world simply explode from adorableness
if scp-999 and baby Yoda ever crossed
those multiversal barriers and met we
can explore all of these questions along
with any others you may have down in the
comments seriously comment it we dare
you but to get things started we figured
we'd make the animatron pit the
foundation's lankiest nightmare monster
scp-096 against the internet's Trevor
Henderson's siren head sorry Slenderman
you're just not cool anymore so without
further Ado let's kick the animatron
into gear and see how this wild battle
plays out it's time for scp-096 versus
siren head Ricky and Elliott a pair of
aspiring travel YouTubers from
California were taking a vacation to the
Pacific Northwest to spend some time in
the area's beautiful Lush forests
however while the duo were both big fans
of travel for its own sake they weren't
just here for the trees and fresh air
you see despite their jet-setting
lifestyle Ricky and Elliot subscribers
and Views hadn't exactly been phenomenal
lately turns out hiking Vlogs and GoPro
footage of the two of them jumping into
absurdly blue water and Bali weren't
exactly that interesting to people who
weren't actually there but Ricky had
formulated an ingenious plan to pull the
two of them out of obscurity they would
hunt down and film real footage of the
legendary siren head a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on YouTube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survived
the experience they'd be framing their
golden play buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two Californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the Pacific Northwest and as such
were already shivering from bone deep
cold the second issue was food while the
two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their walk and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that Ricky and Elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this instance wanting to take
all the siren head glory and Cloud for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky Google Maps
app to guide them as such as the night
was creeping in the two aspiring YouTube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation
and to make matters worse Ricky and
Elliot had been experiencing some
strange feelings for the last couple of
hours when they'd gotten particularly
deep into the forest that dread-inducing
sensation of being watched by something
lurking just out of sight a gaze with
some unknowable and Darkly malicious
intent boiling behind it these two poor
saps had no idea what was in store for
them tonight and wouldn't you know it
the one watching them right now wouldn't
even be the only monster after them
after an expectable amount of bumbling
and buffoonery Ricky and Elliot managed
to gather up enough Tinder to make a
semi-respectable campfire they could
sleep out here tonight then set off in
search of siren head or civilization
whichever came first in the daylight the
next day the duo did what they could to
remain chipper in spite of the ominous
circumstances sure they were trapped in
the depths of the woods alone but think
of the amazing Vlog footage they'd get
they'd be like the next blur which crew
except they'd live hopefully but as the
duo sat next to their campfire they felt
that ominous sensation again the hairs
on the back of their neck started
standing up they felt Shivers that
didn't just come from the cold more and
more they started to feel certain that
something in this forest was watching
them something ancient and powerful and
evil that's when they heard The Telltale
crackle of radio static and their
skeletons almost jumped out of their
skin could it be him the patron saint
have gone missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell silent
all they could hear was the crackling of
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid mines also predisposed to sense
siren-headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with a number of frightening
sightings of tall thin things and radio
static that seemed perfectly consistent
with siren head activity that's why
they'd come here in the first place but
had they come here to their deaths the
two needed to distract themselves or
they'd go mad from the paranoia they
decided to share a few fun little
anecdotes of the travels they'd had
before meeting one another showing the
photos they'd saved on their smartphones
Ricky had been to Hawaii Tahiti or abora
Fiji Saint Lucia and the Maldives
clearly he liked his vacations warm and
Sandy Elliot on the other hand tended to
like his trips to be a little more
adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous cave
systems and of course a little guided
mountaineering one photo that Elliot
showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when Ricky asked Elliot where exactly
he'd taken this picture strangely enough
he drew a complete blank baby somewhere
in Canada or Siberia or something like
that but it was a hell of a trip
whatever the case he remembered having a
great time it was such a tiny detail but
when looking at the photo Ricky couldn't
help but notice something something in
the background a speck of white sure not
exactly newsworthy in the snowy mountain
range but this wasn't snow it was a
speck of white that seemed to be a
slightly different shade than the rest
of the mountain strange perhaps it was
just some tiny particles stuck on the
lens whenever the photo was taken the
two continued to chat and warm their
hands against the fire having no idea of
the horror they just awoken in doing so
over a hundred miles away at an SCP
Foundation containment site researchers
and guards walked around the perimeter
of a huge airtight metal cube reading
off Diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the great metal cube only
a faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal then the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging fourlorn Knuckles it
turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping series of
horrendous slobbering sobs whales of
pure pain and despair someone in the
room screamed close your eyes and hit
the deck
exactly
what they learned well enough from the
infamous incident
096-1-8 Containment Breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until
it run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did as they
were told hitting the ground closing
their eyes and covering them with their
hands just to be safe that's when the
solid steel of the cube was torn open
like crepe paper from the howling raging
scp-096 Broke Free Galloping on all
fours through the nearest wall
shattering it and spraying debris
everywhere as mobile task forces were
dispatched should track the rampaging
Abomination and try their best to clear
the path ahead as it sought out its
Target one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room woe but
tied the poor fools who saw that
Monster's face back in the deep dark
forests of the Pacific Northwest the
presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for Ricky
and Elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the
the squeals and crackles of radio static
they saw shapes moving amongst the trees
tall and thin like long spindly limbs
while neither wanted to voice Their Fear
they were both thinking similar things
if there really was a monster out here
why hadn't it killed them it had all the
Time in the World to do it but that was
just it wasn't it it had all the time in
the world so why rush it had every
Advantage it could take its time and do
this exactly how it wanted to Rick and
Elliott had made themselves the perfect
prey and as they saw a huge lith figure
suddenly separate itself from the trees
they began to wonder if it was really
worth it to risk both of their lives for
YouTube Cloud either way it was now
probably too late for regrets Ricky and
Elliot's Jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before
them they recognized the awful modeled
skin stretched over the monster's
40-foot frame they saw the grasping
hands up above the nightmarish faceless
head split into a pair of sirens
pointing in different directions each
one filled with gnashing teeth and
slithering tongues it was even more
terrifying than they could possibly have
imagined siren head speakers crackled
into life in his Stout
Ricky and Elliot stumbled backwards as
siren had Advanced its speakers still
bleeding hateful static neither could
move or speak only watch as its long
gnarled fingers reach from the dark to
grasp them there was a terrible pained
whale in the woods after that but it
wasn't coming from Ricky Elliot or siren
head it was distant at first but soon
became louder and louder as the Force's
point of origin came barreling towards
them even siren head couldn't help but
turn to see
scp-096 a flash of terrible white Fury
come charging towards them in the dark
knocking down all the trees in its path
leaves and pine needles scattered trunks
exploded into splinters nothing would
stop the shy guy from claiming its prey
nothing would stop it from destroying
Ricky and now as it approached Elliot
made the Fatal mistake of looking at its
face too 096 lunge ready to go in for
the kill when siren head's hands closed
her on the shy guy slender torso in one
fluid motion with surprising strength
for its scrawny build it hurled the shy
guy into the distance smashing another
several trees in its path the words
hissed out of its speakers but 096 was
only down for mere moments it sprung
back up on its hind and four legs and
started Galloping towards Ricky and
Elliot again who were still frozen in
place this time just before the Shy
Guy's terrible claws could close around
the two hapless wannabe YouTubers down
came siren heads clenched fist pounding
096's head into the dirt overhead mobile
task force helicopter circled wearing
their scramble goggles and trying to get
a visual on the situation unfolding
below they could hardly believe what
they were seeing down there with some
other unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept 096 in its rage state only a
handful of anomalies on record have ever
been shown of being capable of such a
feat it seemed that they were dealing
with something serious here down below
the battle continued siren head had a
unique advantage over most other
combatants facing scp-096 it was an
extra dimensional being with no eyes
merely an innate psychic awareness of
its victims around it not unlike how
scp-096 detect people seeing its face in
photographs or videos without need for
any kind of direct contact as such it
was impossible for siren head to see the
shy guy's face and thus impossible for
the shy guy to ever actually direct its
aggression against it whether or not 096
would kill steel siren head's intended
prey was another matter entirely in the
night's first minor miracle Ricky and
Elliot remembered that they'd been born
with working legs and decided that right
now would be an excellent time to use
them they turned and began to run while
siren had continued beating the shy guy
into the dirt sprinting with all their
might however the growing distance
between them only aggravated the shy guy
further it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a
beeline for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total Annihilation
tonight is no
Ricky and Elliot screamed as they heard
its pounding Gallop on the ground behind
them closer closer closer than suddenly
defying all spatial reasoning siren had
emerged out from the darkness between
Ricky Elliott and 096 being 40 feet tall
siren had dwarfed even the shy guy it
lunged and grabbed the Wailing white
monstrosity holding it as one would a
particularly vicious cat and trying to
keep it in place siren had wanted to
crush the monster's bones and carry on
stalking its feeble human prey who were
currently in the process of getting away
but somehow that was impossible it was
almost like the monster had an
indestructible skeleton up above the
mobile task forces continued observing
this Clash of the Titans from their two
helicopters seeing how siren head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of
subduing the shy guy one of the task
force members joked and maybe we should
hire this guy another chimed in I don't
think we have any ballistic vests in his
size the laughter soon turned to screams
when siren had her 096's flailing body
up at one of the helicopters with
Incredible Force knocking it out of the
sky it greened down to the ground a ball
of fear and violence before exploding
anyone who survived the initial blast
was unlucky enough to have seen the shy
guy's face their screams rang out
briefly before being abruptly silenced
by the monster helicopter Alpha had no
survivors meanwhile Ricky and Elliot had
kept running until their lungs burned
and their muscles pumped thumbtacks
seeing that the chaos was so far behind
them now they took a moment to stop and
breathe recomposing themselves in the
second minor miracle of the night it
looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal those two horrific
monsters had canceled each other out but
Ricky and Elliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson they really weren't that
lucky the last thing the two of them
ever saw was siren head emerging from
the darkness once more the last thing
they ever felt was the monster's
terrible gnarled fingers curling around
their bodies too fast for them to escape
and the last thing they they ever heard
was each other's screams followed by a
sickeningly meaty crunch elsewhere in
the forest
scp-096's whales died down to its usual
mudlin SOB the rage state had ended all
of its targets had been destroyed it
just hadn't been the one to do all the
destroying per se not long after that
helicopter Bravo descended safely and
the remaining MTF members closed around
the blubbering Beast someone black
bagged it and everyone breathed a sigh
of relief knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight what about
the other one the MTF Lieutenant asked
the team's Commander shook his head and
said well let's worry about that freak
later and get 096 back to containment
this place gives me the creeps now go
check out scp-096 look at a picture of
Shy Guy In Space the Shy Guy questions
and theories and scp-096 shy guy Escape
incident
096-1-a Containment Breach for more wild
tales of the world's scariest introvert